games love to sell themselves as a
fusion of two things you love assassin's
creed but lord of the rings star wars
with dark souls combat skyrim with guns
i typically tend to roll my eyes at such
reductive statements but sometimes it
really does end up being the perfect way
to describe a game such is the case with
split gate which sells itself as halo
meets portal and it's one of the few
times i've gone yeah that is exactly
what this game is and also it's freaking
awesome
this free to play early access shooter
has actually been around for over two
years now but recently it has taken the
internet by storm going from a peak
player count of less than 1 000 back in
june to over 67 000 at the time of this
video and growing thanks to its recent
release on playstation and xbox
in an age where the competitive shooter
space is highly crowded and indie
shooters don't really make much of an
impression this is impressive to say the
least it begs two questions though what
makes split gate so damn appealing and
should you play it i can answer that
last question with a resounding yes
let's start with the halo part of halo
meets portal split gates gameplay is
trying to capture a very very specific
part of the halo multiplayer experience
4v4 arena matches sure you got your team
deathmatch and king of the hill staples
of the fps genre but you might notice a
couple of very halo sounding game types
like oddball team swat and of course
shoddy snipers damn can they like can
they do that by using the exact same
name splitgate is making it very clear
what this game is gonna play like which
i would say is closest in feel to halo
reach but with a few key differences
splitgate doesn't have equipment you
pick like reach does and has made the
sprint and jetpack of that game a
standard part of your toolkit there's
also no loadouts thank god and instead
you'll find timed weapon pickups on the
map many of which will feel familiar i
mean
come on this is
this battle rifle is just mwah
i could go on and on about the
similarities but what really matters
here isn't that it just looks like halo
but that it feels like halo it can be
very difficult to put into words exactly
what makes a particular shooter feel the
way it does
unless you're race avick the speed of
movement weapon handling damage output
and physics all combined together to
create a shooter's identity and the
developers at 1047 games clearly have a
strong understanding of what makes halo
well halo and they bring that into split
gate anyone who has spent many late
nights slaying with friends on the couch
or over xbox live will find themselves
immediately comfortable with split
double
gates
if i did have a few nitpicks one would
be that i think the melee just doesn't
have the
it needs and often i regret using it and
wish i just stuck to the shooting
there's also the grenades which are
completely different with their function
only being to shut down enemy portals
doing no damage to players now shutting
down enemy portals is pretty cool but i
do find myself missing some good
old-fashioned fragging
now i've just spent all this time
talking about how this game does an
excellent job of mimicking halo but then
why not just go play halo i hear they
have a new one coming out this year also
don't people usually look down on a game
that just copies another
well unlike call of duty which has been
copied to death over the years no one in
my eyes has quite nailed halo's specific
game feel this directly because 1047
games is a small indie staff and not
burdened with the massive legacy of
expectations and fan demands that come
with a long running series this frees
them up to get weird and experimental
with it which is the perfect segue into
the other half of halo meets portal
indeed every player has unlimited access
to their own personal set of portals
that can be placed on portal approved
surfaces this simple addition opens up a
wealth of possibilities you can pull off
some pretty clever maneuvers like
running away from an opponent and then
getting a surprise flank engaging in a
long distance firefight put a portal
behind him and shoot him in the back i
mean when you can set up a sniper perch
using portals and [ __ ] like this
the potential of the mechanic speaks for
itself one of my favorite things about
the portals is how they enhance existing
halo game types i've never particularly
liked oddball because the whole point is
to get your hands on the ball but once
you do
you can't fire weapons and are
restricted to relying on your teammates
to protect you and boy oh boy they sure
never do that in split gate the ball
carrier can still use their portals this
gives you a lot more agency as you can
do fancy maneuvers to escape opponents
or even close the gap and go on the
offensive with some behind the back
melee bashing some of the most fun i've
had with split gate so far is when i've
been the ball carrier something i have
never said when playing halo now you
might be saying to yourself wow this
looks amazing but also seems like giving
everyone a portal gun would be too
chaotic and a balancing nightmare but it
kind of just works like really well the
slower pace of a halo style shooter
limiting matches to 8 players and well
thought out map design keeps matches
from becoming a mess of portal nonsense
and because the fundamentals of the game
are so good you can start off playing
split gate just like a traditional
shooter and still do well and have fun
taking your time to get used to the
portals but once you start
thinking with portals i'm so sorry that
was terrible you begin to see the depth
they can bring if this all sounds
awesome to you well then you really have
no excuse not to play split gate as it
is free to play it does come with the
now traditional free-to-play trappings
you'd expect and probably have your own
opinion on at this point battle pass
rotating storefront etc thankfully none
of that stuff affects the gameplay and i
personally haven't felt any desire to
engage with it but it is there there's
also crossplay between all three
platforms which is a great sign for the
term health of the player base but that
might explain why i was completely
dominating in some matches on mouse and
keyboard this could cause some balancing
concerns down the line that 1047 might
want to look into but hey i was having a
good time
there is the question of whether
splitgate can keep its growing
playerbase around especially once halo
infinite's free-to-play multiplayer
comes out later this year i think the
portals make split-gate stand on its own
in a way that would allow the two to
coexist but only time will tell but for
now i'm just gonna keep enjoying some
split gate
also i'm just gonna say it i really
think there is a missed opportunity for
this game to be called portal combat
okay okay fine i'm ending the video
you